con actos masivos en teherán y otras
ciudades además de una serie de
advertencia al presidente de eeuu y de
paso al primer ministro de israel nueva
inteligencia desde irak indica que
agentes provocadores israelíes están
planeando ataques contra estadounidenses
poniendo al saliente trump en aprietos
con un falso casus belli cuidado con una
trampa donald trump toda la pirotecnia
resultará contraproducente
particularmente en contra de su mejor
amigo así conmemora iran el primer
aniversario del asesinato del general
qasem soleimani líder de la fuerza de
élite al quds de la guardia
revolucionaria a cargo de las
operaciones en el extranjero
a la nueva generación seguirá su camino
aufé te hará a israel ya eeuu y a todos
sus partidarios en los actos del sábado
estuvieron encabezados por varios de
representantes del gobierno iraní entre
ellos ibrahim en redes y ex candidato
presidencial quien reiteró sus llamados
a vengar la muerte del militar soleimani
fue víctima de un ataque con drones
ordenado por el presidente de donald
trump en el aeropuerto de bagdad el 3 de
enero de 2020 en represalia
teherán atacó una base militar
estadounidense en irak hiriendo a cerca
de 100 soldados las tensiones entre
washington y teherán se han disparado
desde 2018 cuando donald trump retiró
unilateralmente a eeuu del acuerdo
nuclear con irán y volvió a imponer
sanciones al país su más reciente
reacción ha sido anunciar que
enriquecerá uranio al 20 por ciento
alejándose cada vez más del tratado
ambas naciones han amenazado con ir a la
guerra desde junio de 2019 pero la
situación se ha vuelto más tensa tras la
muerte del general